Miley Cyrus posts a new photo of Liam  Hemsworth the 23 year old singer can't  stop dropping hints that she's back on  with her former flame I really don't  think there's anyone hotter  I'm like the luckiest ever take a look  at this pic she posted to Instagram  Sunday  there's Liam relaxing on a couch chillin  with his dog Dora  Miley gushed in the caption quote so  much love in one pic  but let's zoom in on Liam's t-shirt  there notice that happy face it's the  logo for the happy hippie Foundation a  nonprofit founded by Miley and get this  just last month it was Miley who was  repping a Liam shirt she snapped this  selfie wearing a top with the actors  last name emblazoned on the back the  couple have yet to officially confirm  their on-again romance but here's what  Liam told et in May everyone's happy I'm  happy